people of the Internet's retro here and
in today's video I'm gonna give you five
reasons why Animal Crossing New Horizons
is the absolute perfect game for parents
to play with their kids I've been
playing New Horizons since launch with
my five-year-old son and I can tell you
it's been an absolute joy to play with
him so here are my five reasons that
Animal Crossing New Horizons is the
perfect game for parents and kids
number one rewards hard work and doesn't
penalize failures and if you have their
bless with one of those kids who just
like hates to lose I mean hates to lose
yeah me too me too
while most video games prioritize being
the best or having a high score Animal
Crossing doesn't really do any of that
instead Animal Crossing focuses on
rewarding hard work and it doesn't
penalize you too much when you fail in
fact it's pretty difficult to fail at
all in Animal Crossing miss out on
catching a fish there will be more just
down the river run out of space for an
item in your inventory drop it where you
stand and it'll be there when you return
outside of the first few moments with a
game you're never really urge to do
anything I mean sure there are places to
go people to meet with objectives and
tasks to complete but the game never
really forces you into any of these
things it's something you have to kind
of start yourself I mean my son would be
totally content just catching bugs and
fish all day and then taking them to the
museum to see if we got anything new and
that's usually what I find him doing
when he's playing number two it fosters
creativity you know Animal Crossing just
isn't like most other games out there
you're free to explore and decorate your
island as you see fit kids can create a
fenced off orchard filled with various
fruit trees plant flowers craft new
items or use the in-game design tool to
create your own patterns that can be
used on clothing or your islands flag
then you have your home the game has so
many different furniture flooring and
wallpaper options that everyone will be
able to find something that suits their
tastes not to mention the game has only
been out for a short time as I'm
recording this video who know
how many new items people will find in
the coming days weeks and months and
number three it teaches math ladies and
gentlemen meet Tom Nook this savvy
business raccoon has been teaching us
all about home loans since we back in
2001 and while he's lenient in that he
doesn't charge interest kids and adults
alike we'll need to save and pay off
their current loan balance before making
any home upgrades aside from paying off
your home loan kids will also need to
learn basic math when it comes to
crafting as most items require multiple
copies of a material the in-game shop
will also have new items each day and
for the adults and older kids out there
there's the stock market which is a
simplistic take on the real world stock
market with villagers everywhere trying
to buy low and sell high number full I
think without a doubt my son's favorite
thing to do as I mentioned earlier is
just a go around catching bugs catching
fish digging up fossils and then taking
them to the museum seeing what we have
that can be donated in fact there have
been so many times when I see him play
and I look over and he's just walking
through the museum and admiring what
we've created so far oh and he's always
quick to point out which items he's
donated versus which items I've donated
so there's still there's still room for
a little competitiveness as well plus
thanks to that in-game smartphone app
guys he even keeps track of which fish
he's caught that I don't have yet oh
he's always makes sure to rub it in -
and number five our final reason that
animal crossing new horizons is the
perfect game for you to play with your
kids is that you can work
collaboratively you know most of the
items on this list I would have expected
going into Animal Crossing new horizons
but this is one that I didn't really
anticipate I've already mentioned us
working together to complete items in
the museum but we're actually working
together to complete certain building
projects as well my son watched in all
one day as I unlocked a recipe for
building a giant robot we were both
pretty disappointed to see the vast
number of resources required to build
said robot but then I just had to smile
the next time I saw him playing the game
guys I mean he told me he was gonna give
me all the iron nuggets he had he
actually did he went and left them at my
door and then I think he had one gold
nugget he left that at my door as well
so anything that he could do to help
was already starting to look for those
things as he was playing the game just
warms my heart guys just warms my heart
honestly guys like I could give away
more than five reasons that animal
crossing new horizons is a perfect game
to play with your kids
my biggest endorsement that I can give
you is that during this crazy quarantine
environment that we find ourselves my
son and I have had an absolute blast
playing has brought so many smiles so
many laughs between the two of us so now
I want to hear from you guys out there
parents and kids alike let me know what
you're enjoying about playing Animal
Crossing new horizons together if you
have any questions feel free to let me
know of that as well you can hit me up
down there in the comments and I will
talk to you again very soon hope you
guys all stay safe and that you have a
fantastic day thanks for watching